[Musique]
le
derrière les lignes allemandes au
printemps 1917 l'état d'esprit était
défensif
ludendorff miser tout sur la campagne
sous marine et ne voulait pas accumulé
les pertes humaines sur le front sa
stratégie implique et le statu quo
l'ouest il maintenait la pression vers
l'est où la russie a accéléré sa
déconfiture
dans les villes des dix départements
français occupé la troupe allemande pour
une fois sans souci prenait le meilleur
de la guerre
[Musique]
le plan albéric qui portait le nom d'une
heure à valeur des nibelungen avait été
conçu à l'ouest par hindenburg et par le
2nd orf et approuvé par le kayser le
gender feu avait fait construire à
l'arrière des lignes de fortifications
lourdes appelé ligne siegfried par les
alliés
le quartier-maître général prévoyait le
repli de l'armée sur cette ligne de
position imprenable qui raccourcissent
et le front allemand chaque offensive
alliée serait ainsi chèrement payé le
keyser a prouvé que pouvait-il faire
d'autre il avait déjà perdu tout pouvoir
[Musique]
le dispositif de retrait impliquer la
destruction du saillant entre arras et
soissons
le rétrécissement économiser au grand
quartier général de huit divisions des
réserves supplémentaires étaient ainsi
dégagé pour l'offensive
[Musique]
au 5 avril 1917 le mouvement de retrait
allemand sur des positions stratégiques
imprenable était terminé des effectifs
squelettiques garder l'ancienne ligne du
front jusqu'à la dernière minute
la retraite très rapide suivait avec
destruction de toutes les routes
pourront installations et même les
maisons qui étaient dynamiter les arbres
fruitiers été coupée des mines était
placé sur tous les points de passage
avec un soin diabolique les allemands
retraite avait fait table rase
[Musique]
on
sur le front de l'est les allemands se
gardait d'attaqué laissant le fonds
russe s'autodétruire ils craignaient par
une attitude menaçante de susciter chez
l'adversaire une réaction patriotique
à l'automne 1917 juste avant la
révolution d'octobre
l'état major allemand avait réussi
plusieurs opérations de débarquement
dans les îles du golfe de riga
[Musique]
ces débarquements devait permettre de
contourner les armées russe par le nord
en cas de reprise de l'offensive
quand l'armée russe du nord au sud avait
vacillé après l'échec de la dernière
offensive ordonnée par le chef de
gouvernement qui risque et les allemands
avaient organisé la contre attaque
là
[Musique]
à
les russes ne résistait plus guère et
les unités allemandes refouler toute
vente est la raison de 150 kilomètres en
deux semaines
[Musique]
les soldats russes fondée dans la neige
disparaît c'est dans les villages
désertés en mars le nouveau gouvernement
des soviets en décembre demandait la
paix et se heurter aux conditions féroce
posées par les allemands qui profitaient
de la situation
il voulait en même temps transféré à
l'ouest le maximum possible d'unités
combattantes et tenir les riches plaines
d'ukraine pour se nourrir une armée de
conquête occupation s'emparait de la
russie il fallait conclure voilà
pourquoi lénine avait signé la paix
infamante de brest litovsk
[Musique]
victoire à l'ess des engagements à
l'ouest la stratégie allemande n'était
pas gratuite un million de pertes
humaines en 1917 le pari le plus
important de l'état major était perdu
les sous-marins commençait à se faire
dépister par les convois alliés les
allemands n'avaient plus les moyens de
s'opposer à l'arrivée en force de 2
millions d'américains qui se préparait à
débarquer en vagues successives en
france
les allemands en ont bu cazères et de la
patrie seraient conviés à de nouveaux
sacrifices par le grand état major
notre situation disait un rapport de
quartiers-maîtres général ludendorff
existe que nous frappions dès que
possible avant que les américains
achètent des forces importantes dans le
conflit
[Musique]
au début de 19 118 hindenburg et
ludendorff rassemblé forces qui leur
reste pour un effort encore plus grand
il lève les vieux et les inaptes
l'étrange aussi et les enrôle dans
l'armée
[Musique]
123 mille hommes sont ainsi arraché aux
usines et aux mines qui pourtant ne
peuvent se passer d'eux les jeunes
garçons sont placés en tête de liste
l'armée lève ces derniers hommes et
impose sa loi sans résistance possible
le gouvernement est maintenant captifs
comme toute la nation du grand d'état
major et le grand état major conduit
l'allemagne à sa remise
[Musique]
oh
le quartier-maître générale le 2 nov
n'a pas terminé la série de ces paris il
met sur une dernière offensive à l'ouest
[Musique]
les américains arrivent en guerre sur un
air de jazz c'est la musique de l'époque
celles qui vont apporter avec eux en
europe
la parade dans les rues de new york et
continuelle
c'est celle des jeunes hommes qui vont
bientôt monter en ligne dans les forêts
de l'argonne
en france il apportera optimisme leur
jeunesse leur dette et leur dynamisme
ils sont dans leurs besoins ce des
trompettes et des cornées des banjos et
des flûtes de quoi jouer au cantonnement
dans les villes françaises chaque fois
qu'ils pourront
on ignore à l'heure en europe cette
explosion du jazz américain pour la
jeunesse française c'est une véritable
révélation
[Musique]
quelques volontaires pris dans la masse
jean si mam donner des leçon de tango
dans une station du new-jersey il a
abandonné sa saison cyril clément
employé dans une usine de chaussures a
passé trois semaines dans une ferme du
vermont pour se mettre en forme vendredi
voix de l'armée
steve semaine que a abandonné son job
dans une épicerie de wiskott side
dans l'iowa un garçon de ferme nommé mr
là et a pris le train pour s'engager à
des moines
un jeune athlète merwe silverthorne a
rejoint le groupe de ses camarades
étudiants pour un parcours aux chemins
de fer d'un quart demie les hôtes à un
camp de marines en californie s'il verse
horn avait entendu parler de ce camp par
son père il a lu tous les livres
patriotique de teddy roosevelt
gd élevé dira-t-il plus tard dans une
atmosphère de patriotisme je regardais
devant moi droit devant moi pour courir
laventure au delà des mers droit devant
moi
[Musique]
ça
pourquoi
à
moussa
m
ça
[Musique]
les volontaires ne suffisent pas pour
constituer une puissante armée
le 5 juin 1917 environ 10 millions
d'américains rejoindre un mouvement
favorable à la conscription
le secrétaire d'état à la guerre baker à
l'honneur de tirer le premier numéro
le sort tombe sur un certain brad shaw
degré noël dans le mississippi il envoie
un télégramme de remerciement
secrétaires d'état
il est la première recrue des états unis
quatre mille cinq cents autres sont
choisis un parent bureau de recrutement
[Musique]
le corps expéditionnaire réuni ses
premières victimes sur un sol rasées
dans des baraques triste sur le papier
l'armée comme 3 millions d'hommes
faute de fusil et soldats on doit se
borner dans l'immédiat à cinq ou six
cent mille âmes ils combattront avec des
arbres étaient par les alliés qu'ils
apprendront à manier sur les champs de
bataille mais tout de suite on leur
apprend la self défense avec le boxeur
johnny qu'il parte
[Musique]
un sportif en anglais enseigne la
technique pour tuer une recrue écrite à
la maison comme les alliés nous
l'enseignent un fusil n'est rien d'autre
que le support d'une baïonnette
ils nous apprennent à mettre dans nos
gestes le maximum deux aides
[Musique]
une armée ça se fabrique à la demande
pressante des alliés les premiers grands
contingents sont rassemblés en juin 1917
ils ont gagné les navires de transport
hâtivement assemblée le secrétaire
d'état est obligée d'annoncer que les
épouses ne sont pas autorisés à partir
en guerre avec leurs maris qui ont entre
21 et 31 ans pour les soldats l'ennemi
se pèle freddy nombre en allemagne
kaiser bill il chante en partant toutes
les chansons qu'ils peuvent avoir dans
leur répertoire de jeunes américains
m
vva
[Musique]
beau
sans plus
en voilà
[Musique]
les bras
une paille
ça
[Musique]
me voir
baho
pantois
mais
son pays
[Musique]
les aliments
à pont de bateaux y la presse et jeté
entre l'amérique et la lointaine guerre
européenne le transport est le fruit de
l'improvisation car il faut qu'il évite
les scores de destroyers bat pavillon
américain les transports sont anglais
mais aussi français italiens et russes
même il y a des bateaux confisqué à
l'ennemi des milliers d'américains font
parfois la traversée sur des bateaux
allemand baptisé 21 la valse ben ou
autre est saisie dans les ports de
l'atlantique à la déclaration de la
guerre
[Musique]
on
en
[Musique]
l' aventure commence en mer chaque
transport est une cible potentielle
l'atlantique bouillonne de dangers
cachés les vigiles traque les
sous-marins à la jumelle
à chaque voyage sommes les alarmes
généralement fausse parfois trop réelle
mais les escorteurs font bien leur
travail
2 millions d'américains passeront
l'océan sans anicroche on compte
seulement 71 victimes de l'action et
demi
[Musique]
le 27 juin les premiers contingents
arrive en france le général pershing
leur commandant en chef les accueille en
personne il est en france depuis un mois
préparant le débarquement des troupes
les premiers contacts sont décevants pas
de drapeau pas de banderole tendue par
des soldats français ou par la
population civile pas de comité de
réception que font donc les français en
fait la nouvelle du débarquement
américain et est tenu strictement secret
est alors les gens découvrent les
nouveaux alliés au dernier moment et des
municipalités sont prises de court
[Musique]
paris fait des efforts l'indépendance
dès ce 4 juillet 1917 et fêter des deux
côtés de l'océan les enfants de l'europe
sont de retour on les accueille comme
une telle à colonel de l'état major de
pershing invente la formule lafayette le
voici éreinté par trois ans de guerre la
capitale de la france reprend vie une
parisienne note ce jour là dans son
journal que les américains sont frais et
rose comme déchirure
[Musique]
alors
ils s'appellent eux-mêmes les deux boys
et la presse et appelle samy diminutif
de l'oncle sam ce surnom ne leur plaît
pas du tout
quand ils prennent le train hiram dans
les wagons à bestiaux en les appelant
deux boys boulemane
ils sont loin d'être prêts pour le
combat les deux boys il sent une
présence pas encore armés
mais la présence se fait sentir avec un
ton de bravade et même de fanfaronnade
donné par le colonel douglas macarthur
qui à 37 ans il sert à l'état-major de
la division rainbow qu'il commandera
plus tard pour pershing ses meilleurs
chefs que nous ayons un autre officier
le capitaine george marshall est recruté
par pershing pour tous les problèmes
d'intendance de logistique d'un corps
expéditionnaire énorme à la 2e division
la moitié des conscrits viennent de
l'armée l'autre de la marine comme
silverthorne que l'on voit ici au
caporal-chef que qui vient du wisconsin
dans la première division on retrouve
ces clémente et merde et de l'iowa et
josh freeman l'ancien professeur de
tango
[Musique]
d'autres divisions arrive en france
la 26ème la 41e des forces tout fraises
que les généraux alliés voudrait bien
d'incorporer aussitôt dans leur unité
jusqu'au dernier homme est perçu 1,6
pour les garder intact loin de l'emprise
des alliés il craint que les
instructeurs alliés une enseigne la
prudence et le défaitisme
pershing veut entraîner lui même ses
hommes dans un esprit d'indépendance
il veut bien coopérer mais pas fusionner
les américains doivent combat sous leur
drapeau dit il
[Musique]
pendant qu'on organise l'armée les
américains proposent leurs services
techniques les ingénieurs les
architectes sont l ouvrage on répare les
lignes de ravitaillement endommagées ont
construit des gars de marchandises avec
des entrepôts frigorifiques pour la
bière on installe comme à bresse devrait
port de débarquement avec décrue des
locomotives des camps de transit
enrageant ne se voir confier des corvées
ménagères quelques unités se porte
volontaire pour l'action immédiate parmi
les premières le 15e régiment
d'infanterie entièrement composé de
noirs ils sont comme les poilus là-bas
durant
[Musique]
pas sur leurs donneurs en forme le sens
je pense
les saints déjà quand tu ne lis pas
ça
l'argent pour dépenser
on les vend
[Musique]
en
larry c'est au magazine elle
ma
voilà voilà
à la fin des 217 d'autres unités
américaines font de brefs séjours dans
l'étranger dans un bon secteur comme on
dit où les ennemis très provisoirement
ne cherche pas à s'entretuer
il s'agit de les familiariser avec le
front
le 2 novembre 1917 il n'y a plus de bons
secteurs les allemands des six est de
donner aux nouveaux venus un avant-goût
de la vraie guerre sous sa forme la plus
répugnante les raids de trancher
[Musique]
m
sinistre baptême au premier un allemand
trois américains sont tués les français
les enterre avec les honneurs ils sont
les premiers à tomber
l'un d'entre eux et merlot et un jeune
homme venu de l'iowa
[Musique]
sur sa tombe ont fait l'éloge de son
sacrifice
[Musique]
dont les américains vol sur le fond de
l'ouest en 10 218 l'aviation de guerre a
déjà une longue histoire trois semaines
après l'invasion de la belgique par les
allemands en août 1914 l'avion n'était
déjà plus seulement un engin de
reconnaissance les biplans étaient
équipés de mitrailleuses servi par des
observateurs ont lâché du bord des
bombes des obus des flèches d'acier et
grenade zamin
le 1er avril 1915 roland garros un des
as de l'aviation d'avant la guerre pour
être le nez de son monoplan sur un avion
allemand
le pilote et demi ne revient pas les
balles passent à travers les lys en
actions sans la toucher en deux semaines
gare au sabbat grâce à cette invention
géniale cinq avions ennemis coup sur
coup les allemands sont totalement
surpris il devient le premier rang du
monde le secret est préservée pendant 18
jours exactement les allemands
réussissent à le capturer après un
atterrissage forcé ils apprennent qu'il
a des déflecteurs d'acier monté sur son
hélice sur chaque série 200 balles
tirées la mitrailleuse frappe cette fois
les déflecteurs les ricochets sont donc
dangereux pour garros mais les balles le
sont encore plus pour l'ennemi
93% peuvent toucher la cible
anthony fokker un génial constructeur
allemand est sollicité par les autorités
pour construire un modèle moins
suicidaire il invente un procédé qui
permet d' interrompre le tir le temps
exact du passage de dennis l'état major
allemand prend l'exclusivité du procédé
[Musique]
fauquet reconstruite ainsi le premier
chasseur au monde disposant d'une
mitrailleuse au tir synchronisée dans
laxe de l'hélice il apparaît dans le
ciel en pleine bataille des flandres
pendant toute l'année 1915 il a
l'occasion de faire la preuve de la
terrifiante efficacité des attaques
aériennes sur le champ de bataille
les alliés ne peuvent alors lui opposer
un chasseur de sa classe
[Musique]
le fokker à croix noire de maxime herman
et bientôt célèbre sur la ligne du front
le pilote inaugure une tactique nouvelle
appelée tour son score est de 15 avions
abattus mais il est abattu lui même en
juin 1916
son compagnon d'escadrille s'appelait
oswald belkin un superbe pilote plein
d'astuces il comprend que la maîtrise du
ciel ne peut être acquise par des
chasseurs isolé et par des formations
discipline et de combattants
les alliés feront leur profite cette
tactique
il travaille sans relâche avec des
usiniers pour mettre au point l'albatros
il est grand temps les alliés sont en
train d'acquérir la supériorité sur les
champs de bataille de péronne et de la
somme
[Musique]
vers le mois d'août 10 216 belle que
dispose de sa propre escadrille d'élite
de pilotes d'albatros mais en octobre le
vainqueur de 40 combat aérien rapproché
meurt dans une collision avec un de ses
compagnons
[Musique]
l'un des plus adroits pilotes formés
peyrebelle que et mangue fred von
richthofen
le baron cavaliers apprend à voler au
prix de nombreuses mésaventures
[Musique]
fondant sur sa proie comme un épervier
il est vraiment chasseurs
chacune de ses victoires est pour lui un
trophée
[Musique]
à 24 ans richthofen est le héros adoré
des allemands l'as des as
agréable bogard son idole des filles
mais solitaire il écrit à sa maman trois
fois par semaine est passée loisirs à
chasser le sanglier
[Musique]
richthofen n'est pas un chasseur
solitaire
il a son cirque volant 80 pilotes des
neet au triple en pas en rouge il change
souvent d'avion comme le chasseur change
le fusil
le 21 avril 10 917
il compte ses victoires
81 victoires
aucun as de cette guerre ne fera mieux
c'est le baron manfred von richthofen
[Musique]
le chasseur rencontre toujours un autre
chasseur plus adroit le chevalier rouge
d'allemagne encaissent une balle dans la
poitrine
vient-elle désert où les tranchées on le
sait c'est la mort du héros il est
enterré par les britanniques avec les
honneurs militaires
[Musique]
on se massacrent férocement à verdun
quand le cirque de richthofen trouve un
nouveau chef l'ars hermann goering qui a
déjà 22 victoires à 25 ans cet ancien
officier d'infanterie avaient de
l'arthrite et le goût de la bonne chère
il avait choisi de voler les aviateurs
pouvait être indulgent à ce travers
[Musique]
goering apprend à voler dans le cirque
richthofen
il sera le dernier commandant du cirque
volant du baron rouge
le royal naval air service mais d'abord
ces appareils au service de la flotte
anglaise et combat au dessus de la mer
il le sera engagé sur terre que beaucoup
plus tard aux côtés du royal flying
coach en 1915 et 1916 il attaque les
zeppelins au sol à la bombe il participe
aussi à la guerre anti sous marine et
repère les submersibles pour le compte
des bateaux de surface les bombardiers
s'acharne sur les abriter plein
les britanniques ont inventé le
porte-avions très tôt en 1915 l'année v
dispose d'un bateau équipé d'un pont
l'ark royal à gallipoli un casque ou de
l'aéronavale attache la première
torpille à un aéroplane il coula c'est
un bateau turc
[Musique]
la terre les volontaires du royal flame
corse participe-t-elle bataille des
flandres et de la somme sans avoir
beaucoup plus que 24 heures
d'instruction ils affrontent ce que
l'armée allemande peut offrir de mieux
par exemple cirque de richthofen
les anglais n'ont pas fait beaucoup de
publicité à leurs fins ils en ont
cependant il des meilleurs le major
edouard manille qui peu connue en partie
aveugle il a à son actif 73 victoires il
a été tué à l'âge de 31 ans
le capitaine albert ball était un
teenager quand il s'est engagé dans
l'aviation
as des as il jardinait et jouer du
violon avant de trouver la mort à l'âge
de 20 ans
le canadien billy bishop était aussi
sauvage que bol aussi à droite mme
annick il réussit à sortir de la guerre
inde m avec 72 victoires la gloire et
fugace les ans en bénéficient pendant la
guerre
plus tard à l'ira ou sportifs aux stars
l'avion est déjà en train de dépasser
l'aviateur aux exploits des chasseurs le
commandement anglais préfère
l'efficacité des bombardiers lourds
ils remplacent avantageusement les
dirigeables et peuvent transporter des
bombes de 500 livres la grande-bretagne
bien plus que l'allemagne porte
l'offensive dans les airs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les français utilisent beaucoup l'avion
dans la bataille le werder il leur sert
à la fois pour l'observation
l'artillerie et pour l' attaque au sol
leur entraînement et méticuleux
il s'apprête à piloter les deux
meilleurs avions de la guerre le bébé ni
aux portes et le sparta
[Musique]
guynemer à l'air d'un enfant fragile les
yeux ardents d'un tuberculeux il vit à
21 ans comme s'il était né pour balayer
les yeux de tous leurs paiements a battu
lui même à sept reprises il devait
détruire 54 avions allemands le public
l'adoré et le commandement lui demanda
de cesser de voler pour ne pas courir le
risque d'être abattu il refuse à leurs
11 septembre 1917 il disparaissait dans
un nuage
les petits enfants des écoles disait que
georges guille mère avait volé si haut
qu'il n'avait jamais pu redescendre
en ehf en classe aux 75 victoire était
un homme méticuleux qui ne laissait rien
au hasard il avait jamais eu de pépin je
place mes balles dans la cible disait-il
avec simplicité comme s'il visait à la
main charles nungesser avait de la
chance il accumule les victoires entre
deux séjours à l'hôpital et de
dégagement dans paris
nager sert l'idole des foules 45
victoires portait une mâchoire
artificiel
[Musique]
beaucoup d'américains combattait au
front il s'était engagé dans la légion
étrangère et attendait la formation
d'une escadrille purement américaine il
a couru en des kills sûr que les avions
étaient prêts
c'était l'escadrille la fayette
[Musique]
cette escadrille est entraînée prête
pour l'action dans le ciel de france le
13 mars 1916 près d'un an avant l'entrée
en guerre des etats-unis
aucun d'entre nous y écrira plus tard
james norman rôle n'était aller beaucoup
plus haut dans le ciel que le sommet du
gratte-ciel de whole world
l'escadrille porte les couleurs
américaines
l'ambassadeur d'allemagne à washington
protestent les français invente alors le
nom d'escadrille lafayette et peignent
sur les ailes des avions leur propre
cocarde pour bien signifier que les
américains sont des volontaires et
l'escadrille et entre dans la danse au
dessus de verdun
première victoire rockwell de caroline
du sud
premier tué le new york et victor
chapman
[Musique]
romera raul 9 bars et 30 ans citoyen
américain d'origine française les
exploitent ces hommes ne tardent pas à
fournir un thème de choix ou reporter de
la presse américaine
leur épopée devient vite une légende
[Musique]
les journaux et les magazines sont
plaints de leur exploit
les pilotes ont collé leurs mascottes le
lionceau porte poite on sait qu'ils
boivent au bar de l'escadrille des
whisky soda une boisson qui devient à la
mode il serait parfaitement heureux les
pilotes de l'escadrille la fayette
si leur espérance de vie n'était pas de
trois semaines au combat cette
statistique geignarde ne les empêchait
pas de vivre et de s'amuser loin de la
boue des tranchées
il avait davantage immense de pouvoir et
médine et boire dans des endroits des
100 avant de marcher à la mort
[Musique]
à
moi
français et britanniques fournissait aux
américains des experts en pilotage et
les avions humaine car les états unis
étaient entrés en guerre sans aucun
avion de combat la france fournissait
les nuits aux portes et les spas d'auzas
américain
les usines et les ateliers français
devait en envoyer 3600 en ligne pour la
seule année 1918
[Musique]
m
les américains devaient apprendre très
vite ce que les alliés avaient mis trois
ans à maîtriser le combat est rien le
bombardement et la reconnaissance
photographique
[Musique]
edit rickenbacker inde et à sa mairie
qu'un les mieux pourvus en victoire est
un conducteur de 40 27 ans il abat au
combat 26 avions allemands mais il est
convaincu que les beaux jours des
chasseurs sont passés
frank luck est une sorte de billy the
kid en uniforme la discipline est
lunatique il abat 21 bureaux allemands
avec une grande désinvolture et à mes
prix affiché des balles de mitrailleuses
il adore incendiés et ballon ce qui est
un exercice périlleux
les ballons l'observation sont toujours
défendus par des mitrailleuses et des
canons anti aériens qui tire à partir du
sol l'ucm heures sur une de ses cibles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le ciel est plein de 15 coups mais les
plus célèbres d'entre eux se sont
illustrés dans les combats individuels
et quelques-uns ont raconté cette vraie
bataille de chien dans le ciel pour à
oldbury qui a eu la chance survivent ces
combats sont atroces et pourtant il les
mène avec le plus grand sens fort
je n'ai pas dit il le moindre état d'âme
je tire sur mon adversaire
on tourne là au dessus de l'autre on
tire tout le temps
tout d'un coup son engin devient tout
blanc
il tombe comme un mégot de cigarette
allumée
[Musique]
au cours de l'année 19 18 les as passe
soudain au second plan avec leur bizarre
petite machine
[Musique]
le général américain billy mitchell
rencontre boom prennent charge le grand
stratège de l'aviation britannique
tracts shard mitchell sont d'accord
l'aviation doit attaquer en coupe points
les deux côtés du saillant allemand
elle entre dans la guerre comme une arme
autonome spécialisée quand les allemands
veulent contre-attaqué sur l'argonne
pour envahir la champagne 200
bombardiers alliés lourdement chargés
prennent l'air et choisissent pour cible
les zones de concentration de l'ennemi
les aviateurs participent désormais au
combat avec autant d'intensité que les
hommes des tranchées
[Musique]
les as ne sont plus guère qu'un
engrenage dans cette immense machine à
tuer qui est déjà devenue l'aviation du
combat
[Musique]
m
bissau est un américain de pittsburgh
qui s'est engagé volontaire dans
l'infanterie française en 1914 il est
devenu l'âme de l'escadrille la fayette
il est le dernier à voir quitter ce
groupe il a reçu sa décoration comédie
rickenbacker des mânes mitchell 1 à sera
au lof béret n'a pu être décoré et pour
cause le 19 mai et 19 118 son lieu aux
portes a pris l'air pour chasser les
albatros
l'engin de l'oft s'est soudain mise à
brûler avec des flammes immenses les
avions qui surgissaient du haut du ciel
ont alors aperçu loft le héros émergents
du nuage de fumée
il a sauté au sol
sauter pour ne pas mourir brûlé
ses amis lui ont fait les funérailles
des aviateurs ils ont lancé des fleurs
du haut des airs il ne le savait pas
encore mais ils marquaient ainsi la fin
d'une époque celle des vieilles tiges de
la guerre de 14 on ne verrait plus
jamais c'est au bla il avait disparu
dans le ciel
[Musique]